im phoenix studio in bonn begrüße jetzt
professor andreas dittmann er ist
geograf und konfliktforscher hallo herr
rietmann sie haben vor einiger zeit ein
buch über diese konflikte in osteuropa
herausgegeben haben ja vorhin im
vorgespräch erzählt das bisher immer
alles nach bestimmten gesetzmäßigkeiten
funktioniert hat in sachen die
stabilisierung was ist jetzt in diesem
ukraine krieg anders
das einzige was anders ist ist dass es 1
1 größere gesamt spielplatz ist aber das
erschreckende an die an der erwähnten
publikationen mit kollegen zusammen
herausgegeben ist dass man bestimmtes
ein bestimmtes muster erkennen könnten
konnte dass man unter dem stichwort so
genannte russische territorial die
stabilisierungspolitik zusammenfassen
kann und das ganze hat seine vorläufer
mann hat seine vorgänger formen und das
hat bisher immer geklappt nur am
beispiel der ukraine ist es vielleicht
so dass der brocken denen man schlucken
wollte so groß ist aber es hat genau
immer bisher funktioniert also die die
schwächen des westens in seinen
reaktionen genau austariert sich danach
ausgerichtet zwei große schwächen waren
das in die eu nach eigenen statuten kein
land aufgenommen werden dürfte das noch
offene territorial fragen hat und ganz
ähnlich ist entsprechende passus auch
bei der nato und an diesen beiden selbst
auferlegten beschränkungen hat jetzt
russland und hat in der vergangenheit so
das ganze lässt sich bis 22 jahre
zurückverfolgen und dann immer ganz
alltäglich aus bestimmten anderen
ländern die vorher teil der sowjetunion
waren das ist ja das was putin meint mit
größte katastrophe des 20 jahrhunderts
auflösen der sowjetunion die vorher teil
der sowjetunion waren seinen seinem
gesellenstück ausprobiert und es hat
immer funktioniert weil das ist nicht
reagierte protestierte aber und sonst
ich sehr viel mehr hat als freundliche
solidaritätsadressen diese brutale
zerstörung die wir jetzt in der ukraine
sehen sehen sie irgendein hebel der
putin in dieser situation morgen soll ja
angeblich wieder verhandelt werden dazu
bringen könnte einzuhalten innezuhalten
und aufzuhängen
also ist es kann nicht ein ende geben
indem putin in dem russland sein gesicht
irgendwie verlieren wird und es gibt ja
jetzt anzeichen dafür dass man sich so
allmählich in richtung einer lösung
bewegt selensky hat heute drei wichtige
punkte angedeutet schwierig ist dabei
noch sehr dass immer wieder betont wird
aber die souveränität der ukraine muss
unantastbar bleiben das wird genau der
punkt sein um die es gibt wenn alles gut
geht und man auf dem verhandlungsweg
sich aufeinander zubewegt dann wird eine
lösung liegen zwischen der im besten
fall zwischen der russischen
maximalforderung also eine ablösung der
sogenannten republik daniels lohans
gebiet das de facto ja schon
herausgelöst war aus der ukraine einer
internationalen und von der ukraine aus
aus gehindert anerkennung russischen
dominanz über die krim und dann und dass
wir der knackpunkt sein daran hat aber
russland jetzt sehr viel interesse
deshalb auch die konzentration auf die
zerstörung die sie erwähnten mario pohl
eine landverbindung zu schaffen zwischen
lohans donez und der krim unter anderem
eventuell noch ein bisschen grimm vor
lang weil dann wichtiger
wasserversorgungs kanal auf die krim
läuft das wären so in einem
verhandlungssaal mario die russischen
hoffentlich dann maximal interessen und
dann wird man sich bewegen müssen da
muss die ukraine von dem duktus
territoriale unantastbarkeit eventuell
sich im dienste des friedens auch ein
bisschen weg bewegen wo es präsident
biden hat am wochenende von einem regime
wechsel gesprochen der da an stünde im
kreml zwar haben die amerikaner allein
und wieder ein bisschen zurückgerudert
durch den außenminister aber ist diese
forderung angesichts dessen was putin
dort anrichtet ist die nicht die
richtige das ist verständlich hat er
damit als demokrat ausgesprochen was vor
zwei wochen schon andere publik einer
der dafür sehr gescholten wurde mit noch
deutlicheren worten zum ausdruck
gebracht hatte und es gibt die fed kauft
versprecher die sind keine sorgen denn
die sind sehr bewusst lanciert also man
kann sich versprechen und kann dann
sagen ach ich war müde ich war nicht so
drauf und die anderen rudern zurück je
mehr das dann diskutiert wird desto
weiter wirkt das ganze und desto mehr
überlegt man auch nicht nur von putin
der sich wahrscheinlich schwarz ärgert
im moment darüber sondern auch in seinem
umfeld also ist kann versprechen geben
die durchaus mehr wirken als ein klares
statement das gemacht
wie überrascht vor dem hinteren testen
was sie geforscht haben wie überrascht
mag der krämer sein mag vor allem putin
sein über die geschlossenheit des
westens wir haben ja vorhin den
wirtschaftsminister gehört da wird kein
gas und auch das öl nicht in robe
bezahlt das ist ja jetzt sozusagen der
nächste punkt man wird ja sehen wie die
reaktion der russen darauf ausfällt ob
dann tatsächlich das gas abgestellt wird
aber noch mal die frage wie verblüfft
wird sollte muss putin sein aber das was
der westen an geschlossenheit zeigt ja
das ist genau das was ihnen selbst am
meisten überrascht hat dass das was
bisher immer funktioniert jetzt in
diesem fall nicht funktioniert also wenn
man noch mal das ganze in die
langfristige strategie einbaut dann hat
mir ein ganz ähnliches szenario bei
einem land und das spielt eine ganz
wesentliche rolle dass noch ein bisschen
weiter weg von uns war als die ukraine
weil georgien wo zwei teile der eine
teil ist asien der andere teile süd
ossetien von russland definitiv besetzt
sind also die georgier sagen wir sind
auf eure country rock it branche das gab
entsprechende kleinere kriege mit
weniger opfern aber nicht mit weniger
entschlossenheit daher wurde also dafür
gesorgt dass georgien eine offene
territorial frage hat der westen hat
protestiert ist in dem politiker köpfe
gerollt und das war es dann auch am ende
war russland in georgien und der westen
hat nichts gemacht weder die eu beitritt
noch nato beitritt das gleiche setzte
sich dann fort in moldawien
transnistrien also das gebiet östlich
des nester von russischen kräften
besetzt und aus moldawien aus moldau
herausgelöst wurde auch hier wieder
internationaler protest dürfte nicht
sein aber am ende hat sich nichts
geändert und er hat sich nicht geändert
und daraus fehlt hätten wir auch gelernt
das funktioniert genauso kann man es
machen und genau so wurde es dann mit
der krim gemacht dann noch mit dem
vorgetäuschten referendum und dann mit
lohans also fünf lektionen und daraus
gelernt das hat bisher immer
funktioniert aber jetzt ganz überwachung
nicht mehr trocken der ukrainische
überhaupt zu der westen hat die ganzen
jahre nicht vernünftig nicht richtig
hingeguckt und ich schliesse uns da
durchaus mit einer jedenfalls die medien
vielen danke professor dittmann wir
sehen uns daher noch mal wieder um 23
uhr danke für den moment